So,
so the Mecca Medina
distinction seems to be jury,
I would say both complicated
and problematic because,
so,
so t tell me if I'm wrong.
Okay.
Because my understanding is that Mohammed
spent most of the part of his life
that was associated with the establishment
of Islam in Medina and northern neck.
And that it wasn't until he went to
Medina that Islam actually became a force.
So back in Mecca,
although his doctrine
appears to have been,
let's say,
more peaceful,
it was also much less successful as a,
as a both a religious
and a political movement.
So then he left Mecca and I believe
under pressure from the inhabitants,
at least to some degree,
moved to Medina.
And then that's when Islam became more,
uh,
more rep,
more revolutionary and expansive.
And so what do you see now I know that
it isn't universally accepted among the
Islamic community that that Mecca Medina
distinction is a reasonable one to make
because of course the presumption is that
there's an essential unity of thought
across the doctrines.
But,
but given,
given your interpretation and I've
read the a similar interpretation among
other,
among other people,
do you see,
what do you see as hopeful within the
Islamic community with regards to bridging
the gap between the say the earlier works
so to speak of Mohammed and the later,
the later more,
more revolutionary element of the,
of his actions and his faith.
Is there a way that
that can be reconciled?
Well,
so dividing of Muslims into Mecca,
a set of Mecca,
Medina and modifiers,
that's not of course an official this
thing except that anyone really wants to
give to you know who,
which individuals,
which Muslims uh,
at war with us.
And should we be worried about
what about peaceful Muslim?
What about these other
Muslims who are speaking up?
No,
what kind of labels we will give him.
If you said the word Islam most
as a Muslim,
what was the last thing that I look is
that selected and in their selection who
justify their,
actually they said both methods.
Alondra to legacy in Mecca.
Because as I was,
if my sister tells me
you've missed the pair,
you need to get up and say,
I was involved,
some of us for my parents say,
oh come on my relationship with
a lot these intimate and unique,
maybe it's none of your
business to tell him what to do.
And then she would come up with
some other or some other Thursday.
But it's my easy to command and hold on,
I'm sorry.
But then the lithium was going to extent
underused Decisely and I'm not the only
one the other scholars like and
that there are many other scholars
who needs to see a window piece.
I think his mom.
Okay,
okay.
Additional or the culture
as a civilization and at
the same time putting to ban
this violin,
providing courses within Islam.
Try and do that.
Then you'll go to see your work
to make a list of all the concepts
that we really don't have any problem
with people being told to pay five times a
day or is this letter or in the
[inaudible] and all sorts of,
you know,
religious features I think
don't have a problem.
Well,
all of,
that's what they did.
That's the Mecca and Medina,
as you said,
a political philosophy.
They're dishonest.
And the literacy Muhammad,
we just them and that's,
and that's exactly when it was loud.
Okay,
I'm successful and this is just today
I tried to end it in and they say
Paul
to be
what to be emulating.
So that's I think where you were saying,
you know,
the neck of the unit and Poker Martha
classification that we applied
social sciences has its problems.
But this was sort of simplifies
because it focuses oh,
after you should what it should.
Okay.
So you see this as an externally applied,
um,
uh,
a category system essentially
useful that's useful for,
for,
for outsiders who are trying to assess
the situation to determine who it is that
you're dealing with that might be regarded
as an ally and who it is that you're
dealing with.
It might be regarded as a fault,
so to speak.
And that would be on the more
militant end of things is that,
that,
that that's a reasonable
way of looking at it.
That's reasonable.
That's a reasonable way of looking at it.
But also if you take the moderate
versus extreme classification or
categorization that has
become common placed,
it does is tell you what,
when we look at that model,
we think of people who
are not using by us.
We're,
if you look at Medina,
you will see that there are hundreds of
thousands of Muslims who do not apply
violence now,
but who do preach about
and they do move peach,
the Makino legacies and
they believe it should be.
It should be instituted.
And in places where the guests,
where you get a majority of these,
none of violence and the types,
the center,
this has applied and forces we alone.
So I think that the toms
model is an extreme.
I just was not good enough.
They don't cover the
well and they also don't,
they don't also seem to
bear any relationship to the
internal diet dynamics of
the faith itself.
So that that's also problematic.
Okay,
so does that,
because you have to keep
going back to the theology,
you have to keep going back to the
internal debate among Muslims are a on and
how to be late to the hospital.
So I personally think Mecca and
Medina is much more useful as a tool,
as an external perceptual framework for
understanding the problem we face is
Islam,
then x team versus versus
white bread and all the,
all the other terms that we have.